we are live now on the Xbox one with DC
Universe Online so we decided we would
bring in Brandon Ralph from DC's legends
of tomorrow so he could get his inner
Adam on and see what he can do against
this super heroic content if Superman
you and Adam you who would win that
fight Superman is Superman so ultimately
Superman would win but I think the atom
would give him one heck of a fight
because the fact that he can shrink down
the subatomic level Superman would email
it up find a match to strength against
strength and all those things Superman
wins no doubt but but Adam might be able
to you know outmaneuver in some way you
watch this it says inappropriate for
children
okay so what's going on here is like
this apocalyptic event is happening
right now it's the final showdown of all
of these heroes in the future so this is
kind of like a flash-forward
okay this is what the world's come to
kind of like our show like this is what
yeah the future holds and we have to do
something to change it exactly it
becomes reality Joker's still up Mark
Hamill which is awesome
it's amazing a dead character sir ears
were charging and now he's he was like
recharging in the Sun you know the drill
I had the dog been there it's great it's
a beautiful time ooh right to the face
we actually took some time to go back do
a little walkthrough of your career okay
characters that you brought to life and
we kind of did some inspired by is here
well I say first we have Superman I've
been looking at here there's a little
small compared to how I am right now but
you know so it's a pretty good attempt
your version was super buttery there's a
good guy and then he kind of turned into
a villain you know but I like I like
that he's gonna go fight the good guys
looking good in the suit I'm really a
little bit jealous of tutting his
forearms
he's doing some real he's doing some
real good work in the gym ah throwback
Adam so you did a lot of research of
like Adam comics we haven't roll right
I'm really happy that I have an EXO
skeleton suit and not just tights ivory
envisioning the suit but it's pretty oh
I think it looks prettier I really like
it and I liked how the helmet is kind of
cool and
dips down I think this is a really cool
recreation I think it's pretty awesome
you want to create a character if you
want to jump in the game so you can
choose whether not be a hero I mean I
think that's a great choice um now you
get to choose your kind of attitude and
personality flirty look at ya Jimmy we
should be called douchey is Lee alright
now this is how you fight it's your
weapon so you can have things come out
of your hands or you can use a
one-handed weapon or staff or dual wield
right so hand blasts you would be a lot
like Adam but what color should my hair
be it's a good question I build it black
oh you deal I could be a leopard you can
totally be a pattern you know there's a
wolf skin or there by cashews but
they're kind of in a style almost that
they color actually right it's got just
some loafers yeah I like the socks with
the ax this is good this is it right
here this is it
i socks we're gonna go play some
basketball it looks good I think it's a
good let's good
I came in it real it wants to be comfy
and you never know when a game of
basketball is gonna break out earth fall
out
now we're gonna jump into the game just
one of the first missions you see as a
hero when you've taken Batman as your
mentor and it features the Scarecrow
Adam versus Scarecrow yeah it'll be good
Tech versus terror mm-hmm so here comes
some of the coaches and Adam Joe given
the smallest yes we put that in there
specifically I'll blast him you know I
can blow myself thankfully no but I
wanted you to feel the fear in trouble
the Scarecrow he's messing with my mind
yeah oh this if I'm fighting
hallucinations oh oh
who's the nations of Huntress and Robin
and
my friends yeah get behind this that
game stuck yeah break out of that I mean
my soda Cola get those for a buck 75 and
a street corner vending machine totally
FDA approved oh yeah low sugar content
yeah sure go so there's the real
Scarecrow this is for real he's not
quite as tall okay and he huh when you
were fighting before heart one shot at
him
what well he's frail yeah he's all right
handcuff him pretty confident aren't you
bein uh I got this we move I guess
learned Oh Oh blog kidding punch them to
get it once again click see you got him
here much faster than I anticipated and
bring on the whole place down it's kind
of what you got to do have to feed him
before you take those four pillars right
good thing you got a suit for this Chi
out is something I could use to shrink
down right now Matt it's definitely
brute force with the building caving in
and a big beam in his hand am I not
gonna do it no no help so Oh get him get
him
maybe ah all right so that was your
first experience in DC Universe Online
on Xbox one what do you think well you
know it helps to have a fight
coordinator but as a heck of a lot of
fun and now I might be a little bit
addicted don't tell my wife
don't forget to check us out on Xbox one
I'll see you later
Clark Kent's parents names were ma and
pas ah